non-minimalists
all right what is the etiquette for the
appropriate size and cost
of wedding gifts now i do have a
pithy answer but we tend to ramble on a
little bit anyway
so my pithy answer for april's question
about etiquette and
size of wedding gifts is expectations
are an anchor of discontent
so i think if we are expecting
a certain number of of what by the way i
i got some of the worst wedding gifts
like
i think the expectations from the other
people are often really strange
i had four bread makers four i don't
register for any of those bread makers
i don't eat bread
yeah and so four people independently
decided to buy you a bread maker
yes yeah i think it's like again this is
i don't know if they were registered
anywhere so that's
that's kind of the yeah that's i
couldn't tell you right yeah um
but but what i do know is we got those
and
i would never even i'm sure carrie used
it once one of them once or something
i don't know if we returned the others i
it was so unintentional
and so i think there's something about
expectations here where we have too many
expectations
for what we want but then also we have
other people have these weird
expectations like it's a wedding i guess
i should buy a bread maker apparently
that's a popular gift at least
from the sample size of one now jess the
the the thought of of wedding gifts
we have something in our minimalist rule
book um at the minimalists.com
rulebook it's just a free e-book that
people can download
and one of the rules in there has to do
with gift
those two rules actually there's a gift
giving the minimalist gift giving rule
and then there's the minimalist gift
getting rule
which is fascinating because as the
minimalist what we say is
if you want better gifts you have to ask
for better
gifts because quite often what we do and
people think that was minimalist we're
just gonna say
humbug don't give me any gifts well
that's that's inconsiderate to the
people who want to add value to your
life
and so i don't think gift giving is a
love language but i think contribution
is a love language and sometimes people
want to add value to your life by giving
you a gift so instead of telling them no
tell them what you're saying yes to now
a gift registry is one way to do that
but what are some of the best gift
registries that you've seen what are
some of the best
gifts that people ask for well i think
especially for people who are
on the more minimalist side of things a
great option for them would be an
experience
registry or a honeymoon registry um if
they value
experiences over things it's such a
popular choice for couples right now too
it's awesome register on sites like
honey fund um
is one of the more popular ones and
couples can go on and they can list
specific things that they want to do
together and it's a it's a
a combination where you can add physical
items as well if there are certain
things that you want but
you can break it down as granular as you
want to um from like we want to do
a massage on our honeymoon in
bora bora or whatever wherever you're
going um
wichita yeah and your guests can just
like log on and contribute to
towards those specific things um so that
like
helps i think the guests feel like
they're giving something
specific which is which is good
especially for like i think the older
folks
uh and in families and stuff like that
uh but it's a really great option and
then couples
get to you know take the trip that they
really want or have those experiences
that they really want rather than just
accumulating more stuff
but i do think that setting up some sort
of registry is super important to your
point
that you don't get anything that you
don't actually want you have to give
them options and let them know
what you do want so you don't get what
you don't want yeah
it's the registry thing is interesting
to me because it feels like
okay you could buy me gifts but here's a
list of the things that you can buy me
but it also makes sense for a married
couple who
they're starting out so they need items
but but to ask for like the specific
and if you don't want to get me any of
these and don't get me any gifts it just
i don't know there's something weird
there but i i do get it in the same
token well if you don't do it you'll end
up with four bread makers
right that's a good point um i had a
friend who got married i was in their
wedding
uh last year the year before but they
did like a gofundme
and i was like oh this is genius yeah
like it was just like literally like on
the
presents table it just said you know if
yeah please if you want to contribute to
our wedding go here and
maybe was on the invitation or something
but yeah i thought that was a good idea
too i like having both options having a
gofundme which is sort of like this
this sort of blanket you know
all-inclusive thing
but then there are some people that
really want to buy you one thing
specific so instead of giving you a
bread maker they can buy you a massage
which is probably actually cheaper than
the bread maker right
and i'm going to get so much more value
from it as well and so i love the idea
of having both options yeah you got
something pithy for us ryan i do
uh my pith the answer is this gift
giving
is not a shortcut to love and i think
often
we look at uh yeah getting someone a
gift it's like this oh here look i love
you
and um that's that is not that is not
love
love is is showing up it's being there
for that person it's supporting that
person
so you know maybe when you're setting
expectations for those gifts if someone
can't afford a gift just ask for their
support
that's the best way to show love yeah
the the materialistic transaction
is how we often treat love but but love
is not
transactional right it is transcendent
and that's why we talk about language
we talk about gift giving and all these
things but love is is so much more than
that now
you can show that you
want to add value to someone's life with
a gift
but in order to do that you have to be
very intentional with a gift otherwise
it does the opposite it's actually being
inconsiderate
if you get me a bread maker and you know
i don't eat bread or you didn't even
happen to ask the question yeah yeah
well and to the
point of or of the question about
etiquette i think
a lot of people in certain areas of the
country especially like i know i have
family on
long island in new york and it's very
much like oh we spent x
amount of dollars per head for every
guest there so
people want to know that so they know
how to give like an appropriately valued
gift
and i would argue that like gift gifting
and the
spirit of being generous and heartfelt
with your gifts shouldn't be like a
tit-for-tat like transaction um it
should come from a place of like
heartfelt generosity and you want to
give them something to add value to
their life and it shouldn't necessarily
have to
stick to a certain dollar amount
especially if it's outside of your
budget
you